we decided to reshuffle things a little
bit so David very kindly already covered
a little bit the quantum attacks on sath
and also gave an introduction to two
Cooper bags algorithm which is also very
important work of David and his
co-authors I've heard em and I'm going
to talk a little bit more about that and
so David talked a lot about things that
we've we know how to do and things that
we've come up with already to look at
the quantum cryptanalysis of these
systems and also a little bit about
implementation and the main goal of my
talk is to tell you all the things we
don't know because I want you to solve
the problems because I don't know how to
do it essentially so please forgive me
for having a lot of things we don't know
okay so you might think why is this so
we've got a room full of lattice experts
and quantum algorithms experts so why
should you care about see site or I
certainly base crypto systems in general
but I'm going to focus on seaside so
it's the probably the closest to
traditional diffie-hellman or elliptic
curve diffie-hellman is in it's really a
drop in post quantum replacement and and
that is because it's really a non
interactive key exchange so David showed
this very nice picture with the group
action where it's just a very simple
generalized not generalization central
simple quantum equivalent of
diffie-hellman and and it also comes
with pull full public key validation and
both of these things as far as I know
were previously an open problem to do it
in an inefficient way post quantumly and
it's it's the smallest keys of all the
post quantum key exchange candidates to
my knowledge at the moment and it's
relatively competitive speed but of
course if you're a lattice person you'll
think this is hilarious if I call this
competitive so it's much much slower
than lattices but you know you get the
small keys so there's there's some
trade-offs there and it depends a little
bit on your application and also it
means you can have nice pictures of
beaches because we call it seaside
is another reason why you should care
about suicide okay so here's a little
picture to give a little bit more
intuition for what's going on and so we
already saw some of the the proper and
hard math from from David so I'm going
to do the easy math worry to show you a
picture and sort of wave my hands a
little bit
and so in seaside what are we looking at
well on a very sort of high level we're
thinking of this thing as a graph so
I'll explain a little bit more what this
graph is a bit later but it's something
that we call a nice ogyny graph and the
black dots the nodes are going to each
node is going to be an individual
elliptic curve and the lines between the
black dots are going to be I switch
knees so we saw a little bit about
actually how complicated these lines are
in David's talk and which is why I'm
skipping over a little bit now but we'll
go into more details later and on a very
high level view of what you can think of
is you can think of your secret key as
being a path in this graph in this you
know of course this is a small example
in reality or your graph will have
considerably more nodes than whatever
this is thirty or something an exponent
exponential number of nodes and your
public key will be the endpoints of that
path so that you know you think if your
public key is going to be this elliptic
curve which is going to be an endpoint
and your secret key is going to be an
ISO Janee which is a path okay and so
David talked about Cooper Berg's
algorithm to attack this problem and so
what is that looking at that's looking
at solving the hidden shift problem and
the shift is then the shift within the
graph right so that the shift the hidden
shift is the hidden path
so and this these numbers are incorrect
I made a typo let me just find a pen
so there's a missing bracket so the the
most recent the the most recent
improvement in asymptotic complexity of
Cooper Berg's algorithm for the hidden
chef problem was in 2011 and and that
time complexity should be two to the
square root 2 plus o of 1 all times the
square root of log p and that's been an
improvement from the previous complexity
that was the same thing but with one
point one point seven seven times that
thing
so the asymptotic complexity of of
Cooper Berg's
algorithm is a sub exponential number
and I've lost the pointer where's the
pointer
in my pocket
oh it is okay cool good little in sleep
that say and please look at this this
number not this one and and so of course
compared to as a claw finding type
attack where you've really got an
exponential difference
this is considerably worse but because
the scheme is simpler in some way then
you still get smaller keys than you do
NS idh but this difference with the
sub-exponential rather than exponential
algorithm is what makes it quite a lot
slower than a side eh and so I'm already
gonna throw some open questions like you
to solve so the main open questions on
this asymptotic complexity of course the
absolute you know golden goal is can you
reduce the power of log to piece it can
you turn this square root into a cube
root or something like that can you make
it more superpolynomial rather than a
sub exponential algorithm okay so maybe
that's a little bit too much to ask
because there hasn't been an improvement
in that that recently and you know this
is a fundamental idea but if you can
then that's awesome and please go ahead
and do it if not how about this constant
right so this constant went down from
one point seven seven to square root of
two in eight years
and maybe we can improve it more and if
we can of course that's going to make
you know even asymptotically going to
make a big difference and failing that
of course the last thing you can do to
try and to try and have have an effect
on this algorithm is figure out what's
the smallest of one you can get in the
exponent and asymptotically that doesn't
really matter but of course we're not
really in an asymptotic work world or in
a concrete world we want concrete
parameters for this security level one
three and five so this is actually an
extremely important question when you're
looking at specific parameters and
there's been quite a lot of work on that
in the last two years which is quite
exciting and Chris is going to talk
about all the latest advances there and
the work that he's done to to figure out
what this number should be for the and
for the missed
parameters so these are the open
questions on asymptotics and please go
ahead and solve them yes
find the first open question reducing
the power of log to P I'm just going to
conjecture and this I think is more
tractable than what the question is
stated if you can't reduce the power of
log to P then it will have an effect
across the board for all of the lattice
questions okay that's pretty awesome say
thank you and understandings the mutual
reductions but I think I suspect that
that can be referred
so to possibly give you a conditional
barrier for reducing okay so I'm just
going to repeat your statement for the
for the recording and so Greg very
kindly pointed out that this reducing
this power of log P according to some
reductions of reg F please correct me if
I make a mistake in repeating this would
actually also give a significant
improvement in the best-known lattice
lattice algorithms it might give a
significant improvement now it's on the
recording okay so if you optimize the
reductions as much as you can then maybe
you also get an improvement in the
lattice algorithms so this is it's not
necessarily a very attractive very
tractable problem but you know this is
this is the thing that would really make
a very big difference to the security of
seaside and also lattices maybe if you
go through very carefully okay and so
this is this is the sort of asymptotic
story and the high-level story about
about understanding what the security of
seaside will be
and of course it's quite a new scheme so
in terms of the concrete complexity
analysis it's especially given that it's
actually for a post quantum system it's
a fairly complex quantum algorithm and
us cryptographers who are not strictly
quantum information theorists and bang
our heads against the wall a little bit
trying to understand all of the subtle
questions here they're still probably
quite a way to go on the concrete
analysis but let me tell you at least
roughly where we're at now so when I say
concrete analysis what do I mean I want
to know what should the key size be for
post quantum security level 2 to the 64
2 to the 96 or 2 to the 128 so this is
roughly corresponding to the nist levels
although I don't think they phrase it
this way so this Cooper bags attack in
order to apply it in this context you
need many seaside queries and of course
question number one how many queries do
you need and well actually I'm not going
to talk about this because Chris is
going to talk about this in a lot of
deal detail after after the break but
this is obviously a very important
question for understanding the
complexity of the attack and and in the
case of seaside actually oh that had
this bullet point first sorry so also
how is the attack affected by occasional
errors and non uniform distributions
over the group so this is really a
genuine question this is not me setting
up for later I do not know the answer to
this question and I think this is
definitely a question that needs to be
answered by a quantum information
theorist and who could look into it in
more detail because we're talking about
huge numbers of qubits here and very
expensive queries and so there's all
sorts of crazy things that can go wrong
so I would say this is a very important
question that so far has not really been
explored probably just because we don't
really have the tools there's a little
bit philosophical at moment but it's
something to think about
and and in the case of Seaside's
the queries themselves are actually
hugely expensive and so in joint work
with Dan Bernstein Tania Langer and
Lawrence Penney and who wrote a lot of
these slides actually
so credits for them and we looked at
this question of how expensive is each
query and we did our best to optimize it
as much as we could and as a quantum
algorithm and I'm gonna go a little bit
into more details about that just
because that's the thing I know about
and of course then for the whole attack
you've got this very expensive query
times the number of queries then all of
these other very difficult questions
like occasional errors and so and then
there's the last question which in this
algorithm is very important which is
what about memory so I would suggest
looking at the or we would suggest
looking at the parallel 80 metric for
this because for for the algorithm that
we're talking about we're really talking
about an algorithm with billions of
qubits and so just I know that there's
different terminology used in different
fields so when I'm talking about an
eighty metric what I'm really thinking
about is both taking into account the
memory and the time of the algorithm and
you know multiplying those numbers
together or something along those lines
and a very important part of this if
you're thinking about implementing a
quantum algorithm is of course somehow
trying to paralyze your algorithms so
that you don't have qubits sitting
around that you have to pay for
constantly error correcting just because
they're not working at that moment and
we tried a little bit to do some
parallelization in this in this paper
but there it's not impossible that
there's there's more options there to
help you with having qubits that are
just sitting around and and so in terms
of this memory questions so we already
touched on with Greg's comment before we
just we touched on Reggae Reggae
algorithm whoo
so reg ever looks at how to decrease the
number of qubits that you use at the
expense of time and so in order to get a
polynomial time algorithm you have to
use an exponential number of qubits and
vice versa so it's not really it
interesting it's interesting to see what
the trade-offs would be and what the
best thing would come to be but in terms
of saying this is what I concurrently
want to do it's a very philosophical
question because we don't know how big a
computer contemn computer will ever be
able to build on what kind of time scale
or at least I don't pretend to know that
so one thing to look at for now is just
say I take the fastest variant I don't
care how many qubits I've got and then
worry about what that means later and so
this is you know roughly a summary of
what we want to understand in order to
have a real concrete complexity analysis
in the quantum story and so I don't
understand this question I don't
understand this question chris is going
to cover this one so that leaves exactly
one and that is how expensive is each
query and I said already it's very
expensive so let's have a little look at
what a query is what does that mean and
how can we understand how expensive it
has to be okay in order to do that we
need to go a little bit back to ISO
Jenice and luckily for me David's
already given you some idea as to what's
going on there and so here's the picture
I had before so remember the high-level
overview is that your secret key is a
path in its graph and that your public
key is the endpoints of that path and
here on the slide I've told you in this
example this is definitely a toy example
here my prime it's 419 rather than 2 to
the 512 bits and so what is this example
so the nodes are super singular elliptic
curves which have in this case they have
this form here so this is in the
Montgomery form that David briefly
mentioned at the end of his talk and so
they've just got this one coefficient a
and that completely determines the curve
up to FP isomorphism and so each node
represents an elliptic curve and each
edge represents an ice dodging e so now
here I've written three five and seven
isoh Jenice so in David's talk he talked
about how to compute two Asajj needs and
how to compute three isogi's
and you already saw the complexity go up
from two to three
so here I've got five and seven and
spoiler alert when P is bigger these
numbers also get bigger we get to
something more like 580 yes no it says
nothing so that must be good 587 I think
is the biggest number and so the
complexity of these isogen EES grows as
the degree grows and so let's just have
a little zoom in on this picture to see
all of the information that's being
encoded here so don't worry too much
about what the formulas are but the
point is that if you just take one
little edge here which looks very
innocent you've got two nodes in a blue
line between them and what does that
mean well and you've got these these two
elliptic curves here which we saw some
pictures of in David's talk and these
things have formula which you can see
hopefully is the form X cubed plus ax
squared plus X where a is 51 and 9
respectively and the blue line between
them means that there's a map between
them which is a nice sahjhan e of degree
3 so and I certainly remember it's a
rational map so you can see the
numerator and the denominator are just
polynomials and it should also be a
morphism of groups on the elliptic
curves and the fact that it's a 3i so
Janee is related to the fact that you
see X to the power 3 in the formula so
of course when you get a 5 I certainly
in a seven isoh journey and a 587 iso
journey you're gonna get a 5 7 or 587 in
the power of X here instead of a 3 so
you're talking about something a little
bit bigger
ok so how do we compute these things in
a way that we'll be able to implement
that on a quantum computer so let's
first of all just talk about how to
compute these things and so what are we
doing why do we want to compute that
well we want to find the secret key the
secret key is a path the path is a
series of edges in the graph so if we
can find the neighbors of a curve then
that means we can compute and isogen e
it means we can compute a puff we don't
necessarily have to find the neighbors
using I so Chinese even so long as you
can find the neighbors it
so what's our am minerals fail to
compute a path given a curve ei in the
example I've chosen a 51 find a neighbor
in the isogen e graph so you might want
to make your problem a little bit easier
because here it's got well six neighbors
right it's got two neighbors on the blue
graph two neighbors on the green and two
neighbors on the red um so you want to
be able to find all the neighbors but
let's look at one thing at a time so
let's say I want to find a neighbor on
the three isogen e graph which is just
that blue one and so here now the edges
are just three isogen years all of them
are three I so Jenice so how do we find
the three isogen e is coming from a 51
in this case e a so remember what a 51
meant and remember this example was over
F 419 and so e 51 is just an elliptic
curve with this equation here y squared
equals x cubed verse 51 x squared plus X
so what do we do well we're going to
choose a random point so I used the word
point because I'm thinking of this
geometric picture always that David had
in his talk but all the point means is
just a solution to the equation and I
say it's an F 419 points that means that
I want x and y to be in FP so for
reasons P has ordered dividing 420 420
is P plus 1 what am I going to do with
it then well I want to find a point of
order 3 so remember from David's talk
that when we're talking about computing
ISO Jenice we can it's enough if we just
know the kernel so the kernel in this
case needs to be a group of order 3 a
group of order 3 is generated by an
element of order 3 an element of water 3
in this case is a point of order 3 so
what do we do we times P by 140 140 is
420 divided by 3 and then with 2/3
probability P is going to have order 3
they
for reasons I'm not going to go into way
you can think about it if you want it's
not that hard I guess maybe it's hard I
do know isn't about anyway
so with some probability and P has order
three and there's P sorry 140 times P
has order three which is then something
we can just compute using like elliptic
curve arithmetic algorithms that we've
known about for you know very long time
longer than I was a life I think so we
find a map with the kernel generated by
this point of order three right so this
group generated by the point of order
three there's a group of order 3 so the
map is then going to be a degree three
map and we do this using the value
formulas that David's mentioned in his
talk
all right so there are formulas you can
plug it in and you get your a sahjhan e
so what we'll be trying to do we were
trying to find a neighbor and the image
of the map is the neighbor in the graph
so this is how you find a neighbor in
the three I saw Jenny graph any
questions about this it's everybody on
board because you can take the point at
infinity when you select one randomly
Antron pointed out but you can't select
the points at infinity when you take it
randomly so no it's not exactly 2/3 but
it's almost exactly 2/3 very good
ten points all right any other questions
anyone else want points no okay and so
and we want to we want to not only do
this for three days so journeys we want
to do it for otherwise such needs but
exactly the same game will work and for
the other two examples that we had that
was five and seven okay so this was the
three I submit graph here's the five I
search my graph say we want to find a
neighbor on the five I saw Jenny graph
what do we do well up until here it's
going to be exactly the same right we're
not using three anywhere here we just
say this is the curve we choose a random
point it has ordered dividing 420
luckily 420 is also divisible by five
well a coincidence so with probability
almost exactly 4/5 84 times P 84 is 420
divided by five has order five and so we
can see the same game we find a map with
the kernel generated by this order five
points that's going to be a a group of
order five and the image of that map is
going to be a neighbor on the five
isogen e graph okay and then of course
we can do the same thing for seven
there's the last picture 420 it's also
divisible by seven what a surprise and
then we get this the the neighbors are
going to be the images of maps with a
kernel which has size seven which
generated by this point of order sign
yes and yes so if you want to yes indeed
so if you've got your eye so GT graph in
this case was the union of the three
five and I saw and 7i so Jenny graph and
so you just keep repeating it and then
you have all the neighbors so you don't
necessarily you want to be able to
compute all the neighbors but in the
algorithm you you are going to basically
compute all possible neighbors in the
superposition
so I'm just showing that you can do
orphan
it's answer your question and okay so
this was all an example but this example
of course just makes sense in general so
what happens in general yes and so the
isogen is here because of the parameters
that we've chosen will be always have a
rational x-coordinate so actually what
you do is you choose an X rather than an
X and away yeah
so that sorry the question for the
recording was some of these I such news
will be generated by points with non
rational coordinates and is that a
problem and the fact that these these
things exist in this example is of
course not a coincidence and it's to do
with the the parameter choices in in
Seaside so this is also you want map for
efficient computation of isogen ease in
the first place okay so um what does
this mean how do we do this in general
well we play the same game right instead
of a 51 oh I should have changed that to
an EA I didn't ever mind so you have EA
a general curve over FP you choose a
random point it has Auto dividing P plus
1 and then with probability almost
exactly L minus 1 over L & P plus 1 over
L times P will have Auto L so here you
can see it's very important actually
that L divides P plus 1 otherwise this
doesn't mean anything and the way that I
constructed the example and the way that
in in seaside its constructed this this
will happen and you'll see that on the
next slide and then this group here with
probability L minus 1 over L will have
order L and so you can find the map with
the kernel which is isomorphic to Z mod
LZ and the image of that map is going to
be a neighbor in your L I such a neat
graph yes
it seems to be only divisible once by L
so you will read get all always chunk of
CL torsion so there is a single I so
Jenny you can sell it and say it says
going to be exactly one completely FP
rational l torsion point and then
there's one where the y coordinate will
be square root it's a minus I so Jenny
and you it's not given in that way - I
so Cheney thing you're not sweet
blossoms free - oh but oh yeah you mean
you mean from the negative I can space
the Frobenius and you can't find exact
where you well you can just switch the
sign that's the point this only gives
one direction yes this will always give
you the same direction you could stop
because you don't need many of them you
don't need to do randomness or whatever
you could store one point four but it's
a different you yeah you're always going
for my different curves that's the point
yeah that's why you can't slow the
points you can't store points for for
exponentially many curves yeah so just
to repeat the question for the recording
and so Anton was pointing out that
because he already knows what P is going
to be he knows that there's going to be
always you're always going to find the
same the same point of whether L which
means you've always computing the same
direction
you're always computing the isogen e in
the same direction and so we had some
like acrobatics to to do both ways in
the paper which I tries to sweep under
the rug but and untwine doesn't like
rugs so I'm not doing that now and and
so you're always yeah you're always
going to be ending up going in the same
direction and but that's not a problem
it's something you can solve and okay
so any any or more questions about this
so this is of course that the moment
just a completely classical algorithm
and but each of these things is
something that you can each of these
steps is something that you can
implement in a quantum setting so the
choosing the random point is a problem
that was already solved in the past and
I think my down tanya was that soft for
you alligator plus house Nova and hand
back ok and so there's a there's a
quantum algorithm which is called
alligator not alligator but alligator to
find a random point on the curve um and
everything else is a lip stick curve
arithmetic which on the very high level
you can just break down into a sequence
of basic bit operations like ands and
ORS and X ORS and these things and then
you can apply your your generic quantum
transforms not transforms you can do a
generic machinery to change those basic
bit operations into C knots and tough
leaves and then into T gates and
clifford's and so these are things that
you can absolutely this out this basic
algorithm here is something that you can
implement on it on a quantum machine by
looking at it on the level of bit
operations so this was something that we
were sort of trying to estimate how many
bit operations it was and how many how
much ordered how much it would cost to
compute this place so journey and blah
blah blah
and then Dan comes along and he's like
oh come on guys we should just implement
something that counts the number of base
operations not only bit operations so
then he you know does his thing and then
outputs a number and then you have an
exact idea of how many non any a bit
operations you do and at some point
that's easier than trying to sort of
estimate what's going on so that's what
and that's what our paper is about and
but of course this was just computing
our neighbor right and we need a little
bit more than that to really talk about
computing one query so I'm talking for
too long
so what do we do on top of this so this
is the sort of the very important little
segments of the algorithm is how to
compute and I such any
how do we use that to really use Cooper
burg for seaside okay so computing a
query what does a query do it computes
many paths in the superposition
what's a path a path is a sequence of
steps each step isn't isogen II oh I've
already said that here okay
path is a sequence of a certain ease and
they will have degrees which vary a lot
you know they're going to range from
from three to five hundred and eight to
seven for example or maybe something
bigger later on in life when things get
broken and larger degree isogen ears are
more expensive as we've seen I mean just
from the formula you can see they're
more expensive but at the same time
remember we've got this step in the
algorithm which finds something with
probability L minus 1 over L right that
was on the previous slide we were
finding something with probability L
minus 1 over L what does that mean oh
I've got too many bullet points okay so
these are more expensive and because
you're wanting to compute many different
parts in in superposition you've got an
I such needs of different degree being
computed in superposition what does that
mean you've got qubits that have got
nothing to do because on one sort of in
one place you're computing a three
isogen in another place you're computing
as 587 isogen e this needs to take the
same amount of of time so you've got
qubits that are just lying around being
error corrected in order to make space
for this to happen which i've called
board qubits because they don't have
anything to do so you have to give them
things to do they have to keep them
excited and that obviously costs money
costs well that's suppose it's physical
money yeah sure ok and then you've also
got this probability failure at this
step when you're trying to find a point
of the correct order and that fails very
often for small L right so we saw for l
equals 3 you had something that
succeeded with probability 2/3 and
that's a pretty high failure rate and so
what does this mean this means you have
to do it a bunch of times and so you get
a high enough success rate so this
combination of these two things
the whole query computation really quite
expensive right so this failure given
our inability to control errors it's
quite problematic for quantum
implementation so our paper so this is
the paper with Dan Tanya and Lawrence
this gives quite a lot of optimizations
and ideas and more complex variants of
just computes paths in superposition in
order to try and mitigate that the
combination of these two things there's
a whole bunch of algorithms in there
various levels and I invite you to go
and read the paper if you want to know
all of the deep Nissi gritty details of
how to optimize these things and I
wasn't sure that was the best way to
spend my time now so that's not what I'm
doing
and but there are ways to mitigate this
but so I think on the next slide I have
just how much we managed to do and so as
I already said this paper along with
this paper there's a tool and that
provides software to compute a path
using basic bit operations so you really
break down this in the elliptic curve
arithmetic to compute isogen ease into a
list of bit operations that we
understand how to implement quantumly
and then you just count automatic
palliate tallies of nonlinear operations
and linear operations then what do we do
well I'm afraid all we do this is not
very fun for the quantum information
theorists out there but maybe you can do
something clever we just applied a
generic conversion and so what's this
generic conversion well you take your
sequence of your basic bit operations
with it most be nonlinear ones and you
turn it into a sequence of reversal
operations and then you turn with toefl
ii operations and then you turn that
into a sequence of reversible operations
with at most 14 bt gates so you might
wonder why this is the generic
conversion we use and not the one where
you can turn it into of most eight B T
gates at the expense of ofb measurements
and well this is just what we chose to
do because
is very large for us and it's an unknown
expense at the moment in the context of
surface code error correction so that's
what we chose to do maybe it was a bad
choice please go home and look at it and
tell us if it was a bad choice and but
this is this is what we've done with our
algorithm so we take our classical
algorithm we apply this general trick
generic conversion to get a quantum
algorithm and of course it's possible to
do this faster I don't know how much
faster I mean we saw a great example on
Saturday in the Q sharp talk that when
you really look at you're really trying
to focus on the arithmetic that's faster
for and quantum operations you can you
can do a lot better so there was a nice
speed up from ensure from Samuel shap
and someone else sorry I forgot ah
anyway I should have written it down I
didn't sorry a skank okay great thank
you and so this is this is an open
question which again I welcome you to
look at I told you it's going to be a
ton of things I didn't know how to do
and and so how well do we managed to do
with this with this idea of just generic
conversion so let's look at a case study
and so in like I say we have software so
you can plug in numbers whatever you
like to see what you would get with with
different parameters so in so this CL
NPR that's my self cathartic astrick
Tanya Lang at Lawrence Panty and yos
furnace so in our original paper on
seaside we just took the numbers from
Cooper Berg's 2011 paper and said this
is the complexity approximately so and
we you know we talked a little bit about
the subtleties of memory and those sorts
of things but we didn't go into huge
amounts of detail on what the complexity
would be if the quantum algorithm
because that's a very subtle question
which with well has taken at least
several papers since then to work out
and so this is just based on those
parameters there's a place to start what
do we get for the algorithm that we
looked at what's the cost for one query
in the algorithm that we looked at so in
this example the
I don't feel this F P with P of this
very special form where 70 L 74 is then
the prime 587 and of course this means
the reason we take this special form is
so that we have each small prime
dividing P plus 1 which we saw as an
important part of being able to compute
these rational I so Jenice okay so
what's the number that we get well and
we do look at some different error rates
but just to pick a random one for an
error rate of wanting less than 2 to the
minus 32 errors our best algorithm in
our paper requires this specific number
of non nearly a bit operations which is
just a little bit less than 2 to the 40
this is what I mean by expenses it's
quite expensive and so we really did try
I promise we tried and and because the
previous record was to the 51 so we omit
like we got somewhere between 11 and 12
bits better so then we do our generic
conversion and that gives 40 3.3 t gates
but that's using 2 to the 40 cubits so
that's you know not completely ideal and
you can also save some cubits and at the
expense of just another couple of bits
that's not so bad so this might be a
good a good trade-off to take so you can
also take 45 point 3 t gates using about
2 to the 20 cubits and then what does
that give you in the end it gives you
the total gates for 1 Q on query
counting T plus Clifford and to be about
well almost 2 to the 47 and so that's
just for one query and then we'll see
later on and how many how you can
actually then use that to estimate the
total cost of the algorithm so Chris is
going to talk about the number of
queries and how to optimize Cooper Birds
algorithm to try and push down that
number as low as you can okay so this is
the best we can do at the moment for for
this error rate but this is again to
make it simple enough to actually do
something we've had to put like all of
these restrictions like okay
we say this is the error rate we say
this is the parameter and we ignore
everything that comes from error
correction we ignore so many things
because otherwise it's just a problem
that I don't know how to solve we don't
know how to solve maybe you know how to
solve I hope you do and and so like one
of the biggest questions is what to do
with with errors so the paper that that
I mentioned which has these numbers we I
told you we would look at some different
error rates and we really write down the
concrete ones for these three error
rates so this is a relatively arbitrary
choice the 2 inverse is just to see like
okay suppose that we have the most
amazing error correction ever and then
this is what we're this is this could be
maybe one day in a hundred years be a
thing and this was taken as a sort of
middle a number and then this was a very
paranoid kind of number so and you can
plug in different numbers to the code
and get out different things and see
what's most interesting and but I would
say yeah understanding that error
tolerance of Cooper Berg's algorithm in
this context in this seaside context is
very very important to obtain accurate
concrete concrete numbers because we
just yeah we don't know what these error
rates are and there's many other places
as well where error correction is going
to be you know quite fundamental and if
your edits or error tolerance is high
then the attack will be much better and
if it's lower we much worse and so this
is a sort of open question and of course
this means advances in quantum error
correction would make a very very huge
difference so I would say this is like
the the main points I wanted to make
about Oracle errors and then just
finally I have a list of the open
questions that I I mentioned sort of
summary and for you to go home and solve
so the last one the first one is the one
I just said how do Oracle errors
interact with Cooper Beth's algorithm
what kind of overheads come up from
handeling handeling
two to the twenty cubits and like that's
something that definitely need to
understand especially taking into
account this
and understanding so as far as I
understood at the moment the consensus
or they please correct me if I'm wrong
quantum people and the moment because
the consensus is that like keeping a
constantly error correcting a qubit is
almost as expensive as just computing
with it so um I assume this is going to
give a large number of overheads maybe
you can do some parallelization to save
yourself some work I'm not sure and
there's this sort of maybe a fairly
intractable question but at least
something that should be looked at is
there a quantum algorithm that can give
a win on the asymptotic complexity that
you can actually get to something better
than this sub exponential with a half so
that's really improving this this power
of log P here because if you could then
that's going to have you know long
reaching consequences for this algorithm
and of course these queries are super
expensive so can we decrease the cost of
one query if you can then on a concrete
level you're going to significantly
decrease the course cost of the attack
that's all I have to say thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
the oracle implementation so if I
understand right you have a classical
circa the question is I'm are they're
just repeating for the recording other
aspects of the of the computation of the
Oracle which would be amenable to going
directly with a quantum algorithm rather
than using a graphical algorithm and a
generic conversion easy answer is I
don't know otherwise I'd have done that
instead and but maybe my co-authors have
thought more about this I don't know no
Dan is shrugging so I guess that's a
maybe it's definitely worth looking at
but I honestly don't know
[Applause]